Mối đồng chỉ được quyền ngoại vụ tự xây dực trưng dành đoạn của mình.
Tổ chức có chắc nhận phát hiện nào tạo vụ chỉ màu vệ và sang lòng.
Nhưng không ngàn xem đoạn thay, cán bộ.
Mối đồng chỉ vụ tự hỏi thường xuyên mình đã làm được sang phòng gì của đã chỉ.
Dạ giám nhận việc có thưa, đã bảo vệ kỳ đúng chưa, đã quy tụt được đột mũ chưa,
đã học được cái mới chưa, đã dự mình dự ra đình dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa dựa chức của được và lời ý chưa.
Mối cứ chảy bảo lớm, bị vừa qua được, cả 2 cái tác thức khi được rao quyền lực thì không được chục quan phung lạm của em.
Dù chưa được rao quyền được thì không nạn chỉ không sau bị không phát ngôn chữ chẳng bật.
Không để tâm tư cá nhân, anh giòn để bị chục.
Ở với các đồng chỉ đã được quy hoại nhưng chưa được dựa thiệu cũng cờ không chứng cờ,
hoặc chưa được bộ giảy tình mình tính, cầu thị, tính tục phần đầu,
chưa được bố chỉ không đồng ý ở quy thất bại,
cả không phù nhận quá chính đã phần đầu,
cám bộ của mặt lính và biết từ xói từ xửa,
làm việc tốt hơn, giữ rõnh kép tốt hơn, phục vụ như dựa tốt hơn.
Bự giáo chậm chắc cao hơn, thì không chục quan,
chưa được giáo chậm chắc cao hơn, thì không được mạm chỉ,
đó cũng là thứ đó bản lính kì là phần hoàn, ở trong đàn tạc.